le pari d'ouvrir la saison du théâtre de
dreux avec un orchestre de chambre ait
réussi le premier concert auprès des
abonnés affiche complet cela faisait
cinq ans qu'il n'y avait plus de
formation classique professionnelle dans
le département dur de musiciens de
talent sur département et qui n'étaient
pas utilisés pendant ces cinq années
effectivement donc tout le monde a été
peut-être un preuve frustrés et on est
ravi de se retrouver là pour recommencer
ensemble puis on va faire de concert
plus on va faire deux dates plus envahis
byron cohésion dans leurs caisses et
plus leur caisse va progresser
ici la plupart enseigne la musique ces
professeurs se sont rencontrés lors de
prestations dans de grandes villes
avoirs à l'étranger
mais ils se sentent avant tout leurs
ailières déjà se prendrait tous des
enseignants du département donc c'est la
cohésion entre nous et puis l'intérêt
c'est de rayonner sur ce territoire
le fait qu'on soit tous enseignants
quelque part sur un endroit du
territoire on a tous envie d'aller jouer
chez nous on a envie d'aller jouer chez
les collègues aussi et ça fait cette
cohésion ça amène la culture dans le
territoire en dehors de granby
l'ambition du groupe de taille
respectable soit 17 cordistes est de
rendre les oeuvres classiques populaires
on a une idée très très vieillotte en
fait des instruments à cordes des
instruments en général et la musique
classique
il ya même des des disques j'aime pas le
classique mais ça j'aime quand les gens
on entend toute la journée mais ne
savent pas et c'est vrai que si on peut
aller auprès d'eux on pourrait faire de
la de sensibilisation voilà pour qu'ils
se rendent compte qu'en fait c'est
d'informer de musique formidable musique
comme cette sérénade pour cordes en mi
majeur du tchèque antonin dvorak